alors je vais donner des réponses tu vas
me donner la question d'accord si je te
dis la réponse est jamais de la vie non
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça marche ce
temps mais c'est moi l'animateur 1
il faut il faut pas l'être de strasbourg
d'abord parce que là je fais à rouen le
chemin de ses complets d'accord et j'ai
deux dates à strasbourg il a personne
c'est quoi le problème avec les
strasbourgeois
bah oui mais non est ce que j'ai été
soit drôle et les baux strasbourgeois
vont venir
d'accord as tu vas voir donc on va faire
un pot strasbourg d'accord à strasbourg
jeu à la fin de cette séquence je te
ferai un point ce talent bourde à la
réponse est jamais de la vie du cal est
la question
as-tu coucher avec ma femme c'est sûr je
n'ai jamais rencontré d'ailleurs non moi
ça attaquants moi j'ai jamais couché le
taf âme est la réponse est beaucoup trop
d'argent
comme j'ai payé chez la nonna merci
plaisir et d'ailleurs je voudrais rendre
l'argent bah ça ça me fait plaisir aussi
je n'ai pas encore touché on a toujours
payé les gens oui je vous le dis alors
fait des gestes d'accord la réponse est
une ex une ex chili a eu un rapport avec
franck dans sa loge tout à l'heure non
il était sûr et avec moi non il est moi
aussi moi merci
la réponse est c'est vraiment dommage
c'est vraiment dommage que cyril ne soit
pas nos côtés c'est pas thierry que
voulait dire qu'eric oui merci
sans excuses à l aurais jamais dû faire
ça
delphine ernotte c'est à dire faire quoi
tout d'un problème est que france
télévisions non je me demande simplement
qui quand est ce qu'on va dire et
delphine ernotte qui viennent augmenter
ses parts et des questions c'est la
patronne de france télé je te jure je
l'aï rencontré j'ai rien contre l hyper
sympa sûrement l hyper sympa elle est et
non elle est hyper sympa et elle a des
bons résultats toujours pas là des
tricolores ne fait pas ça c'est comme
chez plus de 60 ans je suis un peu
flipper ça a d'ailleurs été ressentie
sur ses 8 rebonds
sur ces huit cd mais qu'il 82,83
t'inquiète pas je suis sur ces 8 mai
août et sur ses villes génial ben voilà
est content ah ouais je t'avais pas voir
là est la réponse est uniquement le
samedi
quand est ce que tu vas jouer à
strasbourg d'accord c'est faux je vais
jouer vendredi samedi la personne
quoique personne tap quoique a pas une
personne à cette norme zéro mais
pourquoi n'y a pas une personne doit
réserver à roanne semaine c'est bondé il
ya peu un strapontin
mais tu as dis un truc sur strasbourg un
jour puis paris gb d'une nana qui était
en costume folklorique mais c'est mieux
que chez l argent j'ai pas entendu ce
nom j'étais à une sorte de boîte zf 6
mois c'est bon c'est bon merci pour la
réponse et j'adore ça ouais c'est gênant
non soit moi qui adore ou c'est toi qui
as l'air si toi reste whaou j'adore
quand tu me raconte des anecdotes avec
franck
qu'as tu fait dans une chaussure de
frein non on en parle dans la grande
marque à la réponse est le fil rouge de
la grande boucle la réponse est touche
pas à mon poste
quel est ton émission préférée
actuellement
alors
gens qui me disent c'est vraiment de la
merde comment tu fais pour aller là bas
moi j'adore ça déjà